Oh Yeah?
What do you want to bet that we can out chipmunk movie you?
oh no
if they find out our films are inferior, our squeakquels will be demolished!
to the ruins of franchises!
Hey! could you give me some advice on that kid's movie formula?
Some folks frown, or even throw up at which chipmunks movie that I like!
Ready to bash their little brains with a club
gonna whore my film tonight!
You're living in a past world, you dinosaurs!
you're more dated then a calender
your films don't mean dick anymore now!
Cause we're the real chipmunks movie!
Wheres your sequels?
Y'know our films are goddamn money trees
go wear your dresses is in the 1980s!
Cater to your Adam Sandler watchers, you're used to shut up kids folks can't stand.
we'd rather be corny but imaginative
then a literal shit eating band
What we haves adventure thats creative
your CGI sucks balls, LOTS OF BALLS
you can't count all the shits we give, now
Cause we're the real chipmunks movie!
You're written by jackasses, looking for a cheque!
All you've got is a bored Jason lee
keep acting like kids are dummies!
Our business deals with happy meals, make us the real chipmunks movie.
Songs we don't steal with mass appeal, make us the real chipmunks movie.
Cause we're the real chipmunks movie
Yeah, we're the real chipmunks movie
Do you even know how tall chipmunks are?
Yeah we're the real chipmunks movie
go do a crossover with the smurfs!
Yeah we're the real chipmunks movie!
Lick my goddamn ass!
F*ck you!
Yeah we're the real chipmunks movie!
Well that in no way determined anything.
Yes, for such a competitive song, nothing was really accomplished.
Didn't he do something like this before?
Did somebody say something about doing stuff before?
How have we never talked?
Real chipmunks movie!